we're hitting the home stretch here
where we want to be playing our best
football you know the teams that they
typically succeed in the playoffs and
and the ones that have that momentum and
and they're they're ascending into the
playoffs we want to be ascending Drew
Brees after last night's victory by the
Saints thirty forty seven over the
Indianapolis Colts he set records more
importantly the Saints in position to
still have a shot at the number one seed
in the NFC and Drew Brees look when we
consider all-time passing yardage
all-time passing touchdowns for now
all-time completions all-time completion
percentage record after record after
record
he's never been an MVP he's been a Super
Bowl MVP he's been an offensive player
of the year
he's got umpteen five thousand yard
seasons this is our first topic for
today's fill-in-the-blank
drew Brees belongs in the top blank of
all time quarterbacks well I know you
think top five and so we know that III
don't feel as strongly as top five about
Drew Brees and again his greatness and
you know I hate these conversations up
[ __ ] who's the five that you put ahead
of him my my top five right now would be
Rodgers Elway Brady Manning Brett Favre
Dan Marino Joe Montana I put them all in
front of Drew Brees right off the bat
just right off the bat so we're not even
getting into Terry Bradshaw Roger
Staubach some of those guys too that I
think are arguable so to me it's top ten
yes but like I'm at the more of the end
of the top ten okay you mean you said it
there's no MVPs it's a Super Bowl 11
years ago there was there was a playoff
droughts okay there was also that and
you can't be a top-five quarterback when
you have a stigma for you can't go
outside and play on out and the elements
to me just you can't you can't be a
top-five quarterback can we go
okay here's three quarters of the
stadiums in football you wouldn't be
that great there but inside the dome
you're amazing to me that just takes you
out of the top five just do that alone
and yes so that that's where I am with
Drew Brees and I hate saying this
because I still think he's awesome and
of course being the top 10 and anything
in the world would be amazing but when
you get into quarterbacks with Brady or
breeze nobody wants to hear anything in
7 1 or 2 send your mail to Christopher D
Center he says it here I've had a
four-man send that
up here that's right that's what we'll
do we'll have a conversation about it I
have great respect it's just yes that's
where I kind of see it I'm sorry I'll
look at it this way quarterbacks pass
the ball and Drew Brees one of the
greatest pastors of all time from
accuracy production everything
standpoint and I know that Sean Payton
had a lot to do with it
I think one of the reasons Drew Brees
became Drew Brees is because he made the
jump from the Chargers definitely the
same remember Nick Saban said a year or
two ago that if the Dolphins at-sign
Brees remember they were gonna sign
Brees yeah traded for Dante Culpepper
instead
sorry Dolphins fans you can send your
mail to me for bringing that up
save and said he'd still be coaching the
Dolphins if they had signed a through
Brees well I don't know about that yeah
but he's been there longer I know that
yeah I mean because that's the thing if
you're going to be successful in the NFL
you have to have a great quarterback and
Brees is highly talented highly
competitive yep highly motivated great
highly disciplined yep and he has just
kind of quietly put together one of the
most memorable careers we've ever seen
and I got him in the top five I I you
know I yeah yeah I think he's number
five okay the other the top four who
knows yeah but just because you don't
really you're not sure he's top five I
think you're just being recently but
recency bias there but that's okay I've
been raised he buys for the last three
years next topic the blank will end up
with the number one seed in the NFC I'm
going with the San Francisco 49ers I I
just still think of the most complete
team in the NFC and I know that's
dangerous with the New Orleans Saints
cuz they're right there nipping at their
heels but I do think the 49ers will beat
the Rams this weekend and I think they
will go to Seattle and win that football
game there I look at Seattle and Green
Bay you just think there's flaws with
their football team and I understand
their records are the same but their
dirt their schedules have not been as
hard as I think the 49ers are especially
the 49ers I think the 49ers are ability
quality team your tip in your picks in
advance of not one but two episodes of
the Chris Sims on button PFT p.m. joint
megapix podcast you're taking the 49ers
each in the next two weeks I think it's
gonna be the Saints okay I really
yeah I think it's gonna be the Saints
because I think the Seahawks are gonna
beat the 49ers week 1749 is gonna be
relegated to the wild-card I'm kind of
hoping for that I'm hoping for a Cowboys
49ers wildcard weekend game wouldn't it
be great it would I think when the dust
settles it's gonna be Saints at number
one yeah well I mean that cowboy a you
know Seahawks at Cowboys Niners of
Cowboys Saints at Cowboys so that Saints
that Cowboys can't happen but Seahawks
at Cowboys or 49ers at Cowboys will be
unbelievable wildcard weekend football
you're right about that
all right next subject the AFC team
the Ravens don't want to play in the
postseason is the blank ma homey mah
homie mah homie
why would you want to mess with him I
mean that's the team I look at you know
I think you're adverse and I like it
yeah I think you're you're right there
with me on this one though I mean it
gosh it's there too and over the last
two years you know the Ravens are a team
that want to get in your face and play
bump bump
you know bump and run man-to-man yeah
that's good against most teams in
football but not against the Kansas City
Chiefs you've got three receivers who
all got Rockets up their butts and then
you got a quarterback that's got two
Rockets on his right arm and that's
where it's scary that way and the Kansas
City's defense playing better as well I
think it's the Chiefs Mike I agree with
you I mean the Titans I felt like we're
the team that no one would want to mess
with until they lost at home to the
Texans III think I think it is the
Chiefs I mean think about that the other
options in the AFC the Ravens destroyed
the Texans a few weeks ago the Ravens
beat the Patriots by 17 the Chiefs are
the one team you need to worry about and
I hope that the two teams get together
and I hope it snows like crazy
so Patrick mahomes can keep playing in
the snow I mean has there ever been a
player who is taken to playing in the
snow more than Patrick when Holmes I
want to see him playing the snow every
week especially in the playoffs well
when you play two games the way he has
in the snow yeah he's gonna wish for
that I don't want to see snow in that
matchup though because I want to see
Lamar Jackson at full speed I don't want
to see any of the elements affect either
one of the team and I think if it did
get snowy like that I honestly think
that it would be advantage Kansas City
Chiefs a little bit and I
I don't want to see any advantage I just
want to see the field be normal and love
them let them duel it out that way last
one and this one is interesting blank is
not in the NFL right now but he will be
a head coach next year well I mean to me
there's there's three names that jump
out here I mean of course Urban Meyer
all right I mean that's the one I think
we all are thinking of here I will say
mat rule of Baylor Lincoln Riley are in
that conversation too from Oklahoma I'm
gonna go with Urban Meyer I think Urban
Meyer's flirtin for a reason I do and I
think he will be the Cowboys next head
coach there's a good chance of Jason
Garrett and the Dallas Cowboys don't at
least go to the NFC Championship game
but if it's not there I think that
somebody else will snag Urban Meyer's
well that's why he's kind of been
talking about it being seen at the
Redskins game last week I'm going urban
you think that's right what's wears your
head out there III feel like something
is cooking if someone suggested to me on
Sunday that Urban Meyer maybe Bruce
Allen's Hail Mary play to save his own
job as the president of the organization
that if he delivers Urban Meyer maybe
Dan Schneider keeps Bruce Allen around
and I love the excuse that was given
yesterday Terry Maclaurin the rookie
receiver from a hostile yeah that was
divided Urban Meyer to the game like
like a rookie wide out is handing out
tickets to the owners box where am I
sitting
guy I hooked you up with the owners box
you're good to go yeah I know I know the
owner real way the owners owner suite
tickets no problem guys no problem yeah
I'm with you that was a little fishy and
and I think that it look it's it's a
smart play by Urban Meyer because we
spend a lot of time talking about it
people have noticed and whether it's the
Cowboys wear this Washington whether
it's something else I think Urban Meyer
despite the health issues that drove him
out of Florida the health issue that
drove him out of Ohio State he's ready
to load it up again until there's a
health issue that draws him out of the
NFL which I look I don't like to
speculate on people's health issues but
I think it's fair to say I don't really
think that health issues drove him out
of Gainesville or Columbus that's just
my own personal belief and he wouldn't
be sniffing around about coaching in the
NFL where the pressure is not going to
be any less than it was in college if
there are stress
related conditions that caused him to
coach no longer in Gainesville or in
Columbus Ohio so III I'm with you I
don't know how good he's gonna be but I
think he's gonna give it a shot yeah it
does feel that way and yeah I mean
health related issues aka stress I mean
that's all I always looked at it like I
understand there might have been a few
more complications than that but it's a
tough job we do know that but yeah it
just seems like something's in the works
there for Urban Meyer and he's putting
himself out of there and now that you
know the USC head coaching job seems to
be all good there
there was no change made I just feel
like urban kind of shifted his his focus
towards the NFL and somebody's gonna
make a bid for him
you didn't mention Mike McCarthy the for
I know Chris Koresh do you think he will
be with an NFL team as a head coach in
2020 again this is like no inside info
yet I haven't made calls or anything
like that to go who's on your radar
what's going on here but I just I don't
know Mike I just get the feeling here
and we going into week 16 the NFL season
that McCarthy is gonna be on the outside
looking in one more time and to me the
biggest contact school of all is the
fact that he did all this media stuff
the last few weeks to me that tells me
there hasn't there there not a lot of a
lot of interest been drummed up and he's
getting a little concerned and that's
why he's made himself available to kind
of get his name back out there again and
into the circle so I'm gonna say no
right now I agree with you the
back-channel start to operate in
November and December owners start to
figure out who they want or at least who
they're going to consider and if you're
not drawing the interest that you
expected yeah as the owners start to
figure out the universe of candidates
it's time to try to develop a
groundswell from fans from media just to
get this on the radar screen of owners
as they're finalizing the dance card and
III the guy was was gone for 11 months
now all of a sudden it's this exclusive
and that exclusive and that exclusive if
you do more than one they're not
exclusive and I I think it's just an
error and I don't blame the guy for
trying to get a job I don't blame him
I'm not saying he's in the wrong but
there's only so many of these to go
around and it does feel like as of right
now that the interest isn't going to be
where
was because if it was already there if
he knew that he had something locked up
for next year there's no reason to tell
the what your plans are gonna be and
here's what I'm gonna do you don't want
people to know that just go do it
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports